Deadpool is one of superhero comics most
unlikely success stories the crass
violent mercenary has gone from a cult
favourite to the face of a smash hit
film franchise but while Deadpool's
antics on the big screen have been
hilarious not everything in the comics
has been quite so funny he has a look at
some things Marvel want you to forget
about Deb ball he's a murderous
psychopath in the movies Deadpool is a
killer with a conscience and Marvel's
head scratching the popular Deadpool
kills line of comics though he just to
ruthlessly murders everyone he can get
his hands on among the most gruesome and
distasteful moments is when he
straight-up murdered his friend
spider-man by shooting him in the face
and then there was the time he
slaughtered the x-men and then war
beasts furry skin like a coat once
Marvel Comics finished having Deadpool
psychotically slaughter its own roster
of characters they had him move on to
other characters this time from the
pages of famous works of literature
Montana butchering everyone from Moby
Dick Stephanie's a Scrooge to Bagheera
from the Jungle Book
that's gross he's in love with death in
the Marvel Universe death takes a form
of a woman and is most often seen being
courted by the big purple one himself
vanos but during Wade's time under
experimentation in the Weapon X program
he finds himself frequently so close to
dying but he can see and communicate
with her and he falls in love trying to
die just to be with her however Deaf's
jealous Exynos eventually uses his
powers to make deadpool immortal keeping
him away from death permanently
considering Deadpool's romance with for
NASA is the soul of the first film
censors are good you won't see her and
the living embodiment of mortality
squaring off in any upcoming Deadpool
flicks he served himself as a
cannibalistic snack for a time a
Deadpool was a member of the uncanny
x-force a team that took care of the
tasks too dirty for the x-men to face
you're absolutely right at the end of a
particularly brutal battle that Paul's
teammate Archangel finds himself in
rough shape to help nurse him back to
health
Deadpool ends up feeding Archangel
chunks of dead Paul's own flesh in order
to lend Archangel some of Deadpool
superhuman healing factor it works but
it's also incredibly disturbing he's
basically a complete ripoff
while it's been an open secret among
comic book collectors for decades and my
surprise fans of the Deadpool movies to
learn that the character is actually a
complete and intentional ripoff of the
DC Comics character Deathstroke who
predated Deadpool by several years
deadpool creator Rob Liefeld was such a
huge fan of death stroke that he copied
not just the costume and weapon choice
but the character's name as well
Deadpool Deathstroke
you get the idea writer Fabian Nicieza
figured Liefeld's ripoff was so obvious
they may as well just acknowledge it so
he decided to give Deadpool secret
identity the name Wade Wilson has an O
Maj - Deathstroke whose real name is
Slade Wilson
hey subtlety has never exactly been a
strong suit for mr. pool his mental
health issues are played for laughs
given that he's a murderous psychopath
who thinks killing is hilarious as in
love with death and promotes cannibalism
it's pretty safe to say that their pool
has some fairly serious mental health
issues unfortunately in the comics
those issues are played for laughs when
he ends up choosing reformed
supervillain dr. Fong for a therapist
and that's kind of not even the worst
part
Marvel has constantly portrayed mental
health professionals as literal
supervillains who manipulate people in
need for their own ends so look at that
Paul is really funny but his mental
health struggles kind of aren't
especially when as part of his therapy
Deadpool sucker-punched Kitty Pryde it
wasn't even as funny as dr. bongs
classic appearances as Howard the Ducks
arch enemy talk about things Marvel
would really like movie fans to forget
think I'm my friend happiness in the
animal kingdom ducky
like they say though
love strange we could always give it a
try that's gross
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your left a
[Music]